ce qui est important dans cette démarche
c'est qu'à la fois on il y a un souci
d'intégration paysage de respect du
paysage et en même temps d'économie
d'énergie adaptée à la
région vous êtes toujours très nombreux
à nous écrire pour nous demander de voir
et de revoir les maisons qui ont
remporté notre grand concours sur la
maison individuelle organisée par la
rédaction d'Antenne 2 dans C la vie
aujourd'hui donc dans la série maison en
projet voici le trisè execcho la maison
climatique de Monsieur Vivien une maison
vous allez le voir qui s'est tié partie
toute à la fois du climat et de
l'environnement on qualifie de
climatique la maison des Viviens car
elle tire parti au mieux du climat et du
milieu dans lesquels elle est bâtie en
l'occurrence l'arrière pays de
Montpellier que voici la lande la
garigue avec quelques vignoobble et la
bordure du coteau ou un bulldoer prépare
l'emplacement de la maison au sud-est un
vieux village
puchabon les architectes et d'abord
Bernard Vivien se sont fixés des
bien précise c'était respecter le site
parce qu'on avait très peur de faire des
maisons comme on en voit beaucoup ici
style langue de sien typique qui
respecte pas du tout le site et d'autre
part utiliser au maximum les
énergies naturell renouvelables on a
grâce au talu limité les déperditions le
vent passant par-dessus la maison
ensuite on a bien isolé la maison
ensuite on a cherché à avoir le gain
maximum du soleil pour les mois d'hiver
il y avait donc un certain refus de de
vouloir faire une maison solaire avec
des capteurs de capteurs PL disons qui
soit une grande surface captatrice sur
le sur le toit ou devant la maison et
cetera ça ne leur plaisait pas tellement
au point de vue esthétique premier
principe donc le moins de perte possible
en calories la maison tourne le dos au
vent du nord qui passe sur le rambblet
la couverture de terre une très bonne
isolation des murs épais le tout forme
une masse importante de stockage
thermique la chaleur est fournie grâce à
la serre par le rayonnement du soleil il
est piégé par la serre en hiver et ses
calories s'accumulent pendant le jour
dans les murs pour éviter leur sortie de
la maison on tire un volet isolant entre
l'intérieur et la serre sur laquelle de
plus on baisse un rideau de bois le
soleil fournit ainsi gratuitement la
totalité du chauffage pendant 9 mois
pour l'eau chaude seule concession aux
éipement solaire des capteurs appuyés
contre la cheminée et en retrait du bord
de la toiture afin d'être moins visible
l'intérieur est fait de deux niveaux en
bas une grande pièce à vivre avec coin
cuisine la serre et l'espace enfant avec
porte indépendante sur le jardin en haut
un espace détente avec cheminée et la
chambre des parents première réalisation
de deux jeunes architecte œuvre
volontaire de Bernard Vivien cette
maison assurément ouvre la porte de la
vie on pensait que cette maison était un
peu c'est une construction un peu
marginale quoi par rapport à à ce que se
peut faire à ce qu'il peut se faire
couramment ce qui est important dans
cette démarche c'est qu' à la fois B il
y a un souci d'intégration paysage de
respect du paysage et en même temps
d'économie d'énergie adaptée à la région
donc je crois que cette démarche là si
elle est bien comprise il est bon
qu'elle se développe parce qu'elle est
valable pour la maison individuelle mais
elle est aussi valable pour les habitats
groupés est valable aussi pour les
équipements collectifs c'est-à-dire que
on peut allier à la FO la qualité
architecturale a un souci d'économie
[Musique]
d'énergie